hello freak [ __ ] everyone's mad about
everything like Donald Trump read
everyone met Donald Trump read that the
pictures going around on CNN Awards like
it was literally like this Donald Trump
afraid of stairs with like the chyron
the lower third and it's like and it's
like it's Aires and it's like a first
elevators yeah you prefer gilded
elevators but they're they're serious in
a real question they said yeah this is
the kind of stuff that's going on it so
when you did a sta IR or no you are like
yeah you walk up and down there and a IR
s so this could be like the eat it is
pretty but uh to me I'm like you know
and that's why it goes back you know the
fact is I think this is an important
component to maybe making you understand
what happened a little bit better
because you're not in the in that
ecosystem but I think you can relate
because you're seeing it happen
elsewhere is that the gaming media is
dying and they're dying because no one
really trusts or cares trust them or
cares what they have to say anymore
people in ten year olds and fifteen year
olds today are not growing up doing like
I wonder what polygon has to say about
the newest game they go to youtube and
find a guy there that they trust and
believe which is why the only people
unanimously pretty much that came out my
defense where youtubers because they
know that they're the next rung of this
evolution of the way we absorb and
communicate and absorb information and
have news meanwhile these people to your
point or writing clickbait trying to
stay relevant but no one really cares
what they're saying anyway so they're in
their death throes this is a way for
them to take shots at multiple people at
the same time this is what they did the
PewDiePie this is what they did to other
people and PewDiePie one was really
egregious it was egregious but but like
again a lot of that stuff was taken out
of context yes and and a lot I mean
beauty powers agreed oh yeah I mean the
attacks on him oh yeah it was terrible
what Wall Street Journal did to him this
is just a sign of the time these are
people fighting and I really feel this
way and you might disagree but I feel
like a lot of it is these people are
fighting for their lives if I were if I
were a person that was writing open a
journalist a journalist yeah yeah like
if I were I'm sorry to interrupt you if
I were right if I had written in the
video game industry for ten years right
I wrote him gaming in this year for 14
years but if I was a 10 year industry
veteran and I had fewer than ten
thousand Twitter followers and I'm
writing for a site no one reads and I'm
trying my hardest to stay relevant and
to do my thing I'd be pretty mad too if
I saw a guy that
turns on his camera and speaks whatever
he wants and gets the amount of views in
30 minutes I'll get the entire year why
would you be meant because nothing to do
with you what does it has a lot to do
with you because there's only so much
time and space for these people to
absorb things and I'd rather famine
mentality they'd rather go to 350
million people in this country alone and
there's many many more people all over
the world the idea that anybody's views
is somehow or another taking away from
your views is just straight famine
mentality there's plenty of Lies to go
around you're showing it right now with
your new project sure but I'm just like
but I'm just saying like their thought
process sucks
yeah and ostensibly it's actually adding
to their destruction because people are
looking at this like the media for
instance in political in the political
landscape is dying anyway that the
decline is happening Wall Street Journal
put up a piece not too long ago saying
that per-capita viewership on television
is actually starting to be outpaced by
YouTube so that's over now right so like
now you and that's not on video online
or video on demand that's just YouTube
and so people are looking at the
situation and actually precipitating it
happening quicker because in order to
stay relevant they lie or they raishin
pieces I think we should talk about what
happened with PewDiePie like who the
[ __ ] is PD try and what happened sure do
you want to explain in Japanese okay so
PewDiePie is is the biggest youtuber in
the world
he has 55 million subscribers and he's a
millionaire
just to be clear I've never I don't
really know him very well I think I've
had one or two communicate with him at
some point but I don't know him so I
don't really have a horse in the race
he lives in Europe he lives in England I
think he's Swedish or something of that
nature but he lives in England and he
has a massive youtube following every
video he does will have 10 12 15 million
views and you know you're on YouTube I'm
on YouTube in a much lesser sense that's
a lot of views and he pushed the
boundaries in some ways and some
tasteless ways as this is right and the
thing that really caught on was that he
was using this app or this service
called fiber which is this kind of
TaskRabbit kind of thing where it's like
you can pay people to do whatever you
want and he paid a sum of the things he
did were otherwise but he paid these
guys in some country to hold up these
like death to all Jews signs or
something like that as part of a joke
and you know it's something I think it's
somewhat tasteless but he's trying to
make a point whatever point he was
trying to make use try to make a point
it was lost on a lot of people and this
combined with some other imagery he had
been using some like kind of fascist or
Nazi imagery and some other things that
I've been going on over the month I'm
sorry did you want I know your website
like I'm sorry and so eventually the
Wall Street Journal caught wind of this
Wall Street Journal obviously of a
prolific right of center but still
pretty moderate newspaper and basically
went after been tried to delete ride to
destroy him and took a lot of things out
of context then forced Disney's Disney
owns a studio that funds him and all
these kinds of things and caused a lot
of personal and economic destruction for
this Lee they intentionally took things
out of context too and they distorted
the actual intent of what he was trying
to do especially with telling people to
not be Nazis
he was like mocking people that were
being Nazis and they used that to say
this guy is pretending to be a Nazi
right it was a completely dishonest hit
piece in the same vein as the Conde Nast
it does the same vein as the whole Cogan
hit is this right it's it's these people
they know the term punching up they want
to punch up and they think they're
punching up Wall Street Journal's
punching up now on youtubers but really
caused a lot of hilarious
well lunching up on a youtuber that's
the way I look they look at everything
on hilarious it is this guy's a youtuber
he's a guy by himself you're punching up
to attack him because he's the king
because he's a media elite I mean that's
the media elite I mean it's like an
independent reporter attacking the you
know ABC news or something like that
exactly and and to me it was like it
showed a lot of cowardice it showed a
lot of half-cocked thinking on their on
The Wall Street Journal's part to think
that this was going to blow back on them
and it showed a level and and I hate
using this word because I don't think
innately it's necessarily a bad thing
cuz I think it drives you forward but
there's at the level of jealousy at play
with a lot of these kinds of things
that's happening what you were thinking
about before when you were saying that
someone who's struggling to get 10,000
views and a story they write is going to
look at a guy like this that can do one
video where he talks about farts and he
makes you know his 7 million views or
something like yeah I mean there's a
million a year with him
yeah and they're met and they don't
understand it and I get that you know I
look at some people that are famous or
some people that are and you'll have a
platform I'm like I don't get this but
I'm not going to like sit here and like
rain on their parade that's their right
they have an audience that's totally
fine maybe look at yourself in why you
don't
have an audience maybe you look at
yourself and realize that you've been
doing this for so long and you're so
proud of that why isn't anyone listening
to you could it be you you know instead
of instead of looking around for people
to assassinate which is what basically
happening here right I just I find it so
distasteful I find it so destructive
we're at the precipice of a very
dangerous time because the the trust in
institutions no matter where you are now
is just lost and a lot of it has to do
and that's what I was saying with media
precipitating the fall by not telling
the truth by not doing the right thing I
think the media in terms of pullet
politics for instance is really
rebounding from the fact that they
thought Clinton was going to win so they
thought they can get away with saying
and doing anything for that means to an
end
yeah the Donna Brazile thing for
instance where she was feeding questions
to the clinton campaign yeah is so
incredible so shows such a level of bias
and systemic inherent bias they thought
they were going to get away with all
that now no one trusts anyone so when I
see all the stuff I don't know what's
going on with Russia and Trump for all I
know he could be a [ __ ] Manchurian
Candidate you know but I don't believe a
word they say you know like boy when I
read this about Paul Manafort about
slaying about I don't know you a lot
about all this other [ __ ] I've no idea
we were talking about yeah I have to
really do my own research I don't even
know who to trust anymore they did that
to themselves and they precipitated
their own downfall more and more people
are going on YouTube
to listen to people like you to listen
to people even like Alex Jones to listen
to Dave Rubin to listen giant problem it
is a problem because you emotionally if
you listening to me well you it's a
problem because you need people in the
trenches that you trust you need someone
in the press room at the White House you
need someone in the AP that is on the
wire that is telling you the truth but
we can't even trust them anymore right
that's a big problem that's when people
go seek out alternative sources of news
and information and entertainment and
that's what's happening and that's why
they're dying yeah I'm well in many ways
that you sure that big corporate model
is insuring their own demise absolutely
and and it's it's the race for cliques
it's the race for money in the race for
prominence it's the race for relevance
and not honesty yeah not transparency
and not a real objective sense of what
the truth is and what the actual facts
of a story are that's where journalism
is a different thing now because it's
now a entertainment show it's an
entertainment show that also
has the news in it but that's why the
women are so hot that's why the women on
fox news are wearing these tiny little
dresses and they have beautiful legs and
heels on and they're talking about
important issues but they're giving you
a little bit an eye candy while they're
doing it's so transparent to what I see
that kind of stuff I'm like it was a
very attractive woman I'm sure she knows
what she's talking about but I know why
that I know why she sits at the end of
the table
I like when they're aggressive to
welcome megan kelly and she's attractive
and she's aggressive yes she's smart
that's what makes her sexy yeah talking
about but uh you know yes so we're in
this weirdness we're in this weird space
you know yeah we're in this is just very
bizarre space do you feel like this is
like an almost an adolescent period in
human communication that we're going
through this weird growth period where
we have this incredible access to
information and the ability to spread it
like we have now with with social media
and with YouTube and all these different
things where anybody can kind of hop in
and all sudden get a platform like this
PewDiePie guy
PewDiePie wasn't a star it wasn't a
politician it wasn't an actor before
this just a guy yep and he connected
with people and carved out this path for
himself and pretty pretty much anybody
can kind of do that now I mean there's
it's not easy it's not if it was easy
everyone would do it but it is not
insurmountable and I wonder what the
next stage is in terms of the ability to
share information if it's going to
change past where it's at now and get to
some new level yeah I think I think
you're right in the sense that the
internet specifically had taken off so
quickly the world wide web you know is
only 24 years old Internet's way older
but the way we communicate with each
other now is so different than even
Usenet in the 80s or these kind of
university university communications
that they had going out of the 70s where
they were sharing things amongst each
other
you don't need gatekeepers anywhere
there are no gatekeepers you can go
start a YouTube channel now find an
audience gain thousand subscribers make
a lot of money and say what you want and
that's scary to the traditional
gatekeepers and they don't like it and
their their fight against it is so
transparent and it's so self-serving
when I don't we need a media that we can
trust but I don't think we need the
media as it is right now either because
the media we have right now is bloated
dishonest partisan politically and
motivated all these things that don't
really serve a purpose to educating and
informing someone the days of Cronkite
you're gone
[Applause]
[Music]